a little while ago we debuted a
character on our show
kind of a weird idea called the undead
correspondent it was a zombie
correspondent and we said that he was
reporting from Libya but then a fan
named Miguel Gama Linda posted this on
YouTube
I was watching your show and I kind of
noticed something in one of your bits
where you sent an undead correspondent
out to cover the civil uprising in the
Middle East the pictures that were used
in the background we're not completely
accurate in the background that you see
a sign that says ba that is the sign for
the Bay Area Rapid Transit let me show
you the picture close a picture of the
official Clark logo yeah not completely
accurate
not Libya but San Francisco this guy is
claiming that's what he's saying he's
saying well apparently pal you've never
heard of a neighborhood in Tripoli
called little San Francisco check it out
thank you and why you ask is there a
BART sign in Tripoli because the port
system added a new stop recently check
this out as you see if you're traveling
from Daly City to Fremont on the Green
Line
you can continue East all the way to
little San Francisco
nice try Miguel better luck next time
and now do you fans at home I make the
following challenge okay if you've been
watching the show and if you think
you've spotted a small error on our show
reported at team koco.com / haha I found
an error and sent us a link to your
video explanation we'll sort it out here
on the show as we just did let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chump
meat out of the master all right
[Applause]